good and bad news today as far as UK
productivity is concerned the UK has
climbed to place in an annual table to
13th out of 181 countries and ahead of
France the United States and China
analysis by KPMG highlights that
education is key to improving what it
calls the UK's productivity malaise but
it points out the brexit could lead to a
decrease in productivity levels because
of lower trade and reduced EU migration
the Simon Collins's KPMG UK chairman
joins me now said Simon productivity is
a bit of an amorphous subject what
exactly do you mean by productivity I
look at it as the ability of countries
to compete internationally to win in
trade and why have we gone up the table
we've got the table we looked we look at
181 countries been going back a few
years and looking and we published a
league table since 2013 it's based on
five factors things like macroeconomic
stability of the country the institution
stability of the country human capital
talent longevity those sort of things
infrastructure and when you weigh them
all up net we've gone up there's good
news we've gone up from 14 to 13 and so
why have we gone up we've gone I think
there's the catch we've gone up
I think disproportionately because of
the strength of our institutions so when
you look at judiciary when you look at
strength of regulation perceived
cleanliness from corruption the UK
really scores very very highly that
together with macroeconomic stability
and what that hides is actually a slight
decline on some of the other measures
like infrastructure and education and
these of course are absolutely pivotal
going forward I mean where do we stand
on things like education and
infrastructure now I mean we have an
awful lot about infrastructure is
anything actually really happening on
the ground as far as you're concerned
well plenty is happening I mean there's
lots of announcements and lots of
reality around infrastructure we're
talking here not just about the sort of
hard infrastructure like road and rail
and air which are really important and
but also digital infrastructure as well
broadband and so on the answer is lots
of investment going in but perhaps not
as much as some of our true competitor
countries so we spend just under 3% of
GDP 2.7 on infrastructure Canada China
other countries who are our direct
competitors are spending more it's quite
interesting you were talking about the
strength of Britain's institutions and
transparency of decision-making I think
you mentioned at one point I mean and
other people would say that latter fact
has been called into question at the
moment given this we have so much cloud
around the UK's negotiating tactics and
objectives on the brexit negotiations I
think if you put a really broad
geopolitical backcloth on that and then
you look at the UK and you look at
issues like strength of judiciary
independence you look at their stability
of institutions then we still score off
the scale it's a very positive story and
then you know the positioning of the UK
is really very strong I think the
exciting thing about what we're showing
now is with continued investment and
focus on infrastructure and education we
can actually invent a more relevant and
winning economy for the next generation
so one that's based on higher skills on
digital economy and so on and as we've
been hearing there's a lot of
uncertainty in the economy right now I
mean you're very you have your into the
ground constantly you you have lots of
clients all over the country what are
you hearing from them right there well
we're hearing exactly that an
uncertainty actually the way the way
that I get toppled and actually this is
how we see in our own business is
short-term trading is holding up really
well we published 16 growth last year
our clients are telling us short term
trading across most sectors strong as
you ask them to go further out in time
and further away from their own business
they start to get more nervous more
thoughtful and more uncertain and people
are always a bit more optimistic about
their own circumstances and they are the
economy as a whole long day's a story
thanks very much so yes I mean the CEOs
I talked to are as again yet short term
their own business very confident as
they move out to medium term they
identify other factors that they can't
control macroeconomic geopolitics which
could consumer demand for example which
could destabilize them but generally the
sentiment is very strong and trading is
strong